[Music]
he's a young lay is thirty and from
Somalia she doesn't want to show her
face but she's committed to telling how
she was driven from her home my husband
was killed and I was at home with my
children
masked men came into our house they
raped me and beat me I still have the
scars from it that's why I came here is
one of around 1,500 refugees evacuated
by the United Nations from Libyan camps
last autumn they have endured war and
many of them sexual violence every one
of these women was deemed especially
vulnerable by UN staff who arranged for
them to be flown out there now
recovering in this shelter for women and
children in each air before being flown
to Europe funding for the shelter comes
from the EU it's a prime example of
legal migration without the pitfalls of
a perilous Mediterranean crossing
refugees arrive here from detention in
Libya we provide them with immediate
assistance with protection we have a
team of psychologists working with them
so we have what we call a philosophy of
care basically we provide them with
recreational activities with counseling
with we provide them with language
classes to prepare them for resettlement
neasha is a former French colony and one
of the poorest countries in the world it
also has the world's highest birth rate
on average women in Neesha have six
children there's little infrastructure
and economic output is low the West
African nation is Africa's main transit
hub for Refugees and people smuggling is
big business the President of the
European Parliament has come to assess
the situation firsthand Antonio Tajani
says the EU aims to reverse the trend by
providing shelters so refugees are not
driven into the hands of smugglers we
have to stop these groups to profit from
the lives of Africans who died in the
desert and in the seas we have to stop
them completely absolutely mother in
order to help need air support the
refugees as they wait for a resettlement
Europe the EU is pumping money into the
local economy most people like those
here in the capital in the army live
hand-to-mouth
this woman sells snacks for about one
cent each but not many people buy these
men sell tea on the street sometimes
it's enough to buy a phone card
despite rampant poverty measures
president says his country is ready to
help but long term it will need much
more money from the EU it's important
that we wage a tireless fight against
poverty through public but also through
private investment some of the refugees
in the shelter here in the capital have
been waiting more than a year to get to
Europe the UN has been sharply critical
of some EU countries that want nothing
to do with legal migration and refused a
refugee quota move more quickly which
would mean that we could save more lives
we could bring more people from
detention Tunisia he's is one of the few
who have made it this far
and she at least will have an
opportunity to start a new peaceful life
in Europe without having to put her fate
in the hands of smugglers